Is this too much?
Gallup has been tracking American
attitudes on global warming for more
than two decades. In 1997, 48 percent
nationally said that the effects of global
warming had already begun. In Gallup's new
March poll, 60 percent gave that response.
Just 12 percent said that the effects
would never happen. However, a majority in
Gallup's new poll did not believe global
warming would pose a serious threat to
them during their lifetimes. That may be
one reason why the issue ranks low when
pollsters asked about top priorities for
the President and Congress. In a January
Pew survey, 46 percent said that global
climate change should be a top priority.
Of the 19 issues Pew asked about, climate
change tied for second to last place.
More people – 62 percent – said that protecting the
environment should be a top priority.
Terrorism outstripped both as a top
priority at 73 percent. In Gallup's polling,
the public worries more about
environmental problems they can see in
their own communities, such as the
pollution of drinking water, than they
worry about climate change.
Are you concerned about climate change?
Why or why not?
Let us know in your comments. Also, let us
know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe to more
research and videos from AEI.